let's go next to the five one three area
code dollar from five one three who's
there oh hey that's you yeah who's this
Oh specific from Ohio go ahead Mike yeah
I wanted to ask you if you're familiar
with the that's kind of a philosophical
question if you're familiar with the
concepts of free will and determinism
yes I am so would you say that you
believe basically determinism or at
least that free will doesn't exist you
know this is such a bigger question and
I've read so much about this I sort of
am of the mindset you might be shocked
to hear this is someone who is so often
espoused that I don't think most things
in life are black and white I don't see
it as one or the other in the literal
sense I think that you know this is sort
of like the moral relativism question
which is there's often a debate where
it's like is is moral relativism are you
a moral relativist or not do you believe
in free will or determinism with free
will and determinism the best sort of
explanation that most resonated with me
has been that there is of course some
degree of determinism for humans in the
sense that everything that has happened
came from the initial creation of the
universe and we are made of star stuff
and there is sort of a there are limited
confines within which humans exist
that's sort of biological carbon-based
being so like in a sense there is some
narrowing scope in terms of what it is
that any one human is going to do beyond
that the question of whether every
single one of our actions is sort of
predictable if only we had the right
machine everything we are bound to do is
already predetermined in a literal sense
I don't know the answer to that and
quite frankly it doesn't even seem like
that important of a question for how
each of us lives our life on a day to
day basis yeah so first for me the way
that I like to think about it is that
believing in determinism or at least
that free will doesn't exist like like
there obviously
some theories that have include quantum
randomness so that we can't like to
predict even if we do have even if we
were able to measure everything but the
way that I like to think about it is
that it gives me a better understanding
of why people like to do the things that
they do like allows me to think about
perhaps somebody's upbringing why they
would what leads them to become a
criminal for example that's the way that
I like to think about it there's another
element to this and Nassim Taleb who
wrote the Black Swan I don't know if
that's a book you've read he talks about
how even if thing once you sort of
determine where you are on the spectrum
between free will and determinism the
real world is probabilistic in the sense
that even with a certain this is why we
talk about confidence intervals you can
say that with these inputs 95% of the
time the results will fall within these
sort of parameters but 5% of the time
they won't so even if there's a very
strong deterministic sort of
underpinning to human life and the
universe and the world we're still
dealing in a probabilistic circumstance
and that's why you know when you talk
about upbringing
if 95% of the time a certain upbringing
will lead to someone being conservative
that's not a hundred percent of the time
and even if those inputs are
deterministic to a great degree it's not
a hundred percent mm-hmm okay okay all
right well I think maybe we've said
everything everything that we can right
now thank you for the call I appreciate
it very much